people really want is they want to have
an excuse for why they aren't successful
so most people who are poor look at rich
people and try and find a reason that
they can excuse themselves for not being
successful and then say no it's not me
it's my circumstances it's not me it's
other people and I think that if you can
eliminate circumstances and other people
from your list of reasons that you
weren't successful then you only have
one left which is you and then you can
get to work but you have to admit you
have a deficit before you can fill it
and some people don't believe the world
works that way if that belief serves you
keep believing it you know a lot of
people will say like well you you were
lucky you're born in the United States
or you're born to you know a parent that
ate for you to eat and have shelter and
whatever if you didn't and I'm not
saying that that is the situation that I
had but like it doesn't matter like my
situation is irrelevant to you why does
what happened to me matter in any way in
terms of how you make decisions about
how you live your life it doesn't